[Music]
thanks Jessica
alright thanks so much everyone good
afternoon thanks so much for having me
here it's my first time in Berlin in
Germany in general had a great time
meeting a lot of you and just learning
so much from some of the attendings here
um
I'm Gil Hernandez coming to you from
South Florida and I work at treehouse
I'm the front-end web development
teacher and treehouse we have
programming courses and printing web
development courses online technology
school I specifically teach courses
about two FS JavaScript and most
recently react you can find me on the
Twitter's as a QH and most places on the
Internet and I love CSS right that's why
I'm here that's one of my favorite
subjects to teach and talk about so
today I'm going to be talking about some
of the more fascinating and interesting
things happening in CSS right now
because CSS now provides some really
amazing tools right that empower us more
than ever before and gives us more
flexibility over things like design and
images effects design layout colors even
managing and reusing values right so if
you haven't started using or looking to
new these features yet I'm going to
cover just enough to get to using them
and help you begin leveraging these
features to empower your workflows and
improve your projects and we're going to
be looking at a little bit of code and
lots of demos in the next 30 minutes or
so but I am going to put this aside
after the talk and for timing reasons
I'm not going to go into too much about
browser support but at the end we'll be
a resources slide with some links to
that so let's kick things up by talking
about CSS variables
aka custom property so we know that CSS
can be immensely repetitive right and
maintaining it can be cumbersome now if
you're using a preprocessor like that
you already used to declaring variables
and keeping track of values in your
style sheet well as we all kind of know
since not too long ago you can
add variables directly in CFS and like
variables and pre-processors CSS
variables they hold references to values
that then you can reference to write
your style sheets but there's plenty of
differences to using CSS variables over
preprocessor variables and they're
formerly known as custom properties
because you declare them using a new
custom property syntax that means you
can name them anything you want as long
as you prefix them with those two dashes
you go Songo value then refer to that
property name and your CSS to use the
value now for example if you're
repeating the same color value in
different places you can create a
variable that so your font size or base
color you set it to the repeated valid
like you would a regular CSS property
and what's cool is that they follow the
rules of the Cascade so you first have
to declare them on some element and
you'll often declare variables that will
be referenced by many elements like your
base color or based on size on the root
right so we have to scope them to an
element usually the the root and what
that does it's Cookson at the highest
level of the Cascade that way the values
are available everywhere and they can be
referenced and inherited by all elements
now the browser doesn't do anything
right with a custom property or a robot
first so to call the value you have to
use the VAR function to reference the
valued rather now with bar in place you
know anytime you change the value for
the constant property it gets propagated
it gets passed down along to wherever
it's being used and it makes your CSS
work a little less error-prone
and a bit easier right now a property
value can contain more than one bar
function like you see here that's use
two bars to define a gradient it's also
possible to assign a value to custom
property using other variables like in
this gradient custom property here and
you can use them for fonts backs
layout styles and so on so on to about
code duplication now this isn't terribly
exciting just yet right because we've
been able to do this for some time with
fasts or blasts and other imposed CSS
right well custom properties weren't
created just to be the CSS equivalent of
preprocessor variables or even offer the
same functionality right they can also
do lots and lots of things that
sister's camp so let's look at why the
pre-processors in CSS variables they're
like two different entities it's like
they live in two completely different
worlds first preprocessors they don't
run on the browser and they live in a
source file on your machine right and
the preprocessors replaced variables
with static values and they're compiled
to CSS and the browser knows nothing
about those variables in the variables
themselves know nothing about your Dom
structure now on the other hand CSS
variables are entirely more flexible
than preprocessor variables but so when
you update the value of a CSS variable
about the browser updates it anywhere
it's referenced and it does it have
runtime so this makes them incredibly
dynamic and it opens up lots of other
interesting possibilities and just
replacing colors and font values so
let's look at some those for example in
fact you can't update the value of a
variable
from within a meteor query right but you
can with CSS variables you can update
them live inside media queries so for
example we have this gutter variable
here and it's initially scoped to the
root element and then it's reference
within the rule such that need a gutter
with far and then you can use media
queries to provide these new contacts
that redefined the value of the gutter
at certain break points so you can see
that gutter property the values are
updated live at each breakpoint right
the values themselves are sort of
responsive to that now CSS custom
properties or variables they behave like
regular property so that means they can
inherit cascade and they can be scoped
to any selector so here we have the
space button class right and users
variable to set the background color of
the buttons and then instead of defining
that button BG variable at the root
scope like we did earlier we can declare
it on different selectors like button
modifier classes here right button call
out button info and then we assign the
values there and those selectors they
provide a new scope and what's great is
the properties they get resolved
according to the normal and inherit and
inheritance cascading rule size so the
browser or updates values of that button
I've just based on the class or the Dom
element the variable scope to you can
even update CSS variables inline within
the style attribute
that's sort of how live they are in the
browser array so scoping CSS variables
to Dom elements gives us even more
interesting possibility since they
follow the Cascade and inheritance we
can and we could style them based on
where they appear in the Dom so in other
words were going to efficiently set how
an element looks right when it's inside
of another element look variable so for
example to update the styles of a button
component just based on whether it
appears inside a a banner a card or a
modal class you might create descendant
selectors like this to do that right
well with CSS variables we can update
the styles without having to write these
kind of complex selectors or descendant
selectors that is going to couple your
CSS to the Dom structure so what this
does is it makes the components you
build a completely expensive alright so
now the button can display different
font size a color background or any
property just based on where it appears
on the page and the CSS variables
declared on its parent so here that this
button rule is the CSS properties whose
values we want to update dynamically
with variables and then to change how
that button appears inside a banner a
card or a modal you define the different
variables inside the selectors so now
any button class that's a descendant of
banner art or modal can inherit these
properties and the best part is that you
don't have to know anything about the
context right we get this perfectly be
mobile and reusable button clone you can
also do simple calculations with CSS
variables so here I handed use cases
using the calc function to perform
calculations that determine your length
value so this is using variables to
build pixel and values for margins
now the variables cannot only be updated
using inheritance as we saw earlier and
David's talk you can also interact with
them right using JavaScript you can get
and set a CSS values from your
JavaScript and that's where things start
to get really interesting right so in
this simple demo we had the ball that's
moving around the page and it's just
based on where you click on that page
right now the background color and the
CSS transform properties are all being
updated live with JavaScript
and the way you interact with the CFX
variables with JavaScript is with the
get property value and set property
methods so back to the ball animation
this uses variables right to set the
values for the background color and the
XY translation values being created with
alpha and then in your JavaScript it's
able to set the background color and
those translation values with a set
property method so here we're just
setting the values and not getting them
so for example within a click event
listener sending the translation values
to those XY coordinates at which the
clicking happens with position x
position Y properties and then to change
the background color values setting that
that ball BG property to random X L with
a helper function there so now that
you've seen how and where CSS variables
work you should know where they do not
work so you cannot use CSS variables and
selectors you can't use them in property
names either you can only use them in
values they're also not valid in media
query expressions which is kind of a
bummer I wish they were and you can't
use them to create length values like
the middle box rule here that's invalid
and again you should use calc to build
your length values using CSS variables
cool so let's switch gears here the the
evolution of CSS keeps providing more
and more ways to help us make creative
decisions in the browser right because
many of today's features resemble a lot
of tools you'd normally use in your
graphics editor so blend modes or
example you might have worked with some
of these now blend modes are part of the
compositing and blending CSS spec
compositing meaning combining two or
more elements into one like compositing
an image with its backdrop and blending
is a form of compositing that calculates
the mixing of colors wherever an element
in its background over overlaps so it
defines how those colors mix in the
overlapping areas and CSS gives us two
properties to create and blend elements
together so we have a background blend
mode mix blend mode and let's take a
look at some of these so the background
blend mode properly blends an element
with background layer and the background
can be an
a gradient that can be a color and so
for example in this header rule here we
are blending a background image with a
linear gradient and then we're given it
a background blend with a multiply which
it's a common value for that
now what multiply does is it modifies
the background area by multiplying the
colors in the image
by the colors of the linear gradient in
this particular combination makes for
more vibrant and a beautiful background
image right you'll find that the
background blend mode options are very
similar to ones you'd find in Photoshop
rides you have screening overlay dark
and saturation and a bunch more now
mixed blend mode is a little different
in that it blends the the content of an
SVG or HTML element with any content
that's painted underneath it so we're
not just limited to background areas so
that means you can blend or a composite
two or more embedded images together so
for example here this image is inside a
header it has a dark background area and
what CSS we can seamlessly blend them
together by setting the images mix blend
mode to lighten because of that dark
area now when I found out that you could
blend an image element with a background
layer I started using the explained mode
to help give my grayscale images some
life right and in color and create
custom sets of colors for images so for
example it's rounded image and I did
have to place it inside additive or
inside a containing element to do this
but you can give that div or a
containing element a background color or
a gradient and then for instance use
multiply to just blend it together with
the background of its parent and what's
cool that great scale images tend to
have smaller file sizes than color
images so you can take advantage of that
in these grayscale images and explain
those to apply pretty much any series of
colors to your images and you could also
do this with SVG right you can use the
image element to render a raster image
and you give the SVG a background and
then you use your mix blend mode and
this way you avoid writing some of that
extra CSS that's required to make that
image fit inside that if
ah and here's another example of explain
mode being used to create that knock out
text effect and for this one it's kind
of slow but I animated the background
right so you can really see that the
true blending and compositing power of
mix blend mode now another one of my
favorites new cssm it effects that isn't
part of blending and compositing but it
is part of the filters level two spec is
back drop filter so if you've worked
with CSS filters you know that you can
apply a series of these filter Photoshop
like effects HTML elementally you can
have a blur drop shadow very scale
contracts and invert and a bunch of
others well the backdrop filter property
lets you add some of those same effects
but to the area behind an element right
so the way this works it needs at least
two elements to work property properly
the backdrop filter feature so you need
a target element that you apply the
filter to like our field to a rule here
and then you need to element behind or
underneath the target and that's the
backdrop area that's the area that's
going to be affected by and you apply
the filter effects do so for instance
this is setting the backdrop filter to
invert the colors by a hundred percent
and blend them by two pixels so it's so
any area behind that and see I made this
draggable so yep so that that's the
filter element here which so if you take
a look at this later you'll see when you
drag it around you can see the colors in
Kurt in the background oh here we go
I like doing it here there it is there
we go so yeah so the colors are
inverting and then the backdrop here
it's being blended
now the backdrop filters can also
enhance the models and overlay than your
design so for instance this overlay box
there's a filter behind it that blurs
the dye for an area and darkens the hue
to draw more attention to that overlay
box and the content and there animatable
to that's one of the best parts so you
till you have a gallery or a product
page where you need to click to expand
something right
well backdrop filter can enhance that
and make it more interesting so here
it's blurring the background and
adjusting the hue when the image scales
up so being able to apply these kind of
blending and filtering effects the HTML
elements just with CFS really gives us a
lot of power and flexibility when we're
designing and building our projects now
in a similar vein one feature that is
sort of letting us break out of that
commonplace rectangular nature
displaying content on the web if CSS
shapes because our designs usually
consist of shapes like polygons and
circles but our content is usually
contained with these rectangular boxes
well shapes provide a whole new way to
set our how our context wraps or flows
on the page so we're able to use
geometric shapes as CSS values and have
our text flow around those shapes so for
now the the shapes feature only works on
floated element using the new shape
outside property so for instance we can
take this circular image here float it
left in our design and then define an
out shape outside property to turn on
the safe feature that's what makes it
work and then the value you see here the
circle function that's the new function
that's going to create the CSS shape
it's a for example it's going to set the
inline text to flow around the circular
shape of the image so that's pretty neat
but what's what's interesting is that
you can also leverage the box model and
use regular box model keyword values to
flow content around a circular image for
example so the image already uses a
border radius to create that circle or
effect so instead of having a browser to
do a little bit of extra work to
redefine a circular shape you can set
shape outside to border box all pretty
familiar with that
and then the text will follow the outer
image the outer wrap images circular
border now the way you apply a margin
when you're using these box model
keyword values is with the new shape
margin property as per example here
we're setting it to 20 pixels and this
is also a new new property of the shapes
module now the polygon function that's
the one that's going to give you
unlimited shaped possibilities in your
design right with polygon you create a
shape by defining those XY coordinates
for each point in the polygon so for
example you can set a text to flow
around the right edge of a triangle
using three polygon points and that will
give you something like this you see the
content wrapping around the right
slanted edge this one's a little bit
more complex I define multiple polygon
points to set the heading in paragraph
to flow around the contours of my
coworker Nick and yeah use these the
handy CSS shapes editor tool it's a
Chrome extension to create this and a
lot of the shapes I'd experiment with
but polygon and if you haven't seen this
yet it's an interactive shapes editor
that lets you edit polygons points and
you can immediately visualize how your
the text is going to flow around the
shape you set now a feature that works
very well along take long side shapes is
the clip pet so clipping is a longtime
teacher of graphic design that's you
stood partially or fully high parts of a
graphics and CSS the clip path property
lets you clip portions of an HTML
element and like CSS J's we're not
limited to rectangular clipping paths
we're able to draw clipping regions with
basic shapes polygon points even in SVG
and so we use the clip path property and
that's going to create a clipping region
that will set the visible portions of an
element so for example you can quickly
and easily remove background portions of
an image in your design for example this
dark area here and we're giving clip
paths the circle property it's a circle
function and that's one of the basic
shape functions that's going to define a
clipping path
so now any part outside of that clipping
region they become hidden or or clipped
right to reveal the circular image so
using what's great is that using clip
path and CSS shapes they work
hand-in-hand so you can reuse your clip
path values right - to define a shape
around your clipping path they both use
it exactly the same syntax that for
example here we're providing the shape
outside property the same exact circle
function we gave clip back and that's
going to flow the text around that clip
region looks really wide there so in
your markup you can also do this with
SVG right so you use the the clip path
SVG element inside it and you define all
your polygon points and then in your CSS
you can reference that clip app with the
clip a property the URL function and
then you call up the clip path ID and
then that could produce something like
this right so this is a heading with a
div it with a background image and as
you can see that the polygon points they
follow the exact shapes of the
mountaintops so as a result those
portions get clipped and clip out the
the bottom part of the text now to help
you set clipping paths developer Bennett
feely he built this really fun and
useful tool it's an interactive tool
called Clippy and you can use the tool
to create clip paths shakes or just
simply experiment with what CSS clip
paths can do for you right so to give
you an example we've all seen that
trendy slanted header effect on websites
and applications I've seen it done with
pseudo elements and transform so I've
seen it done with SPG's or with an image
what will it - like clip e in clip path
you can really create it pretty quickly
in a few seconds to drag the controls
around to create the shapes then copy
and paste the code it spits out it into
your CSS for example they had a rule and
you and you get that visual effect and
what's great is that when you use
percentage based coordinates it's going
to give you flexible and responsible
clipping paths all right now color
module level 4 is going to give you new
interesting ways to apply color values
in your CSS so you're going to have new
color functions that let you adjust and
modify colors you're going to have new
values for setting the opacity of colors
and one of those is 8 digit hex notation
and this is going to let you set RGB a
channels as regular hexadecimal values
so in other words you get to do alpha
directly in hex by simply tacking on a
pair of digits to to the value so those
last two digits specify the Alpha
Channel of the color we're value of zero
zero gives you a fully transparent color
and FF represents a fully opaque color
and it uses the the regular hexadecimal
system to define the Alpha so if you're
used to defining your values in RGB a or
hsla you'll find that it can be a little
bit unintuitive at first so for instance
if you want to set a 50 percent
transparency you're going to use 80 not
50 and then 80 would be CC 20 is 33 and
so on so it can be a little tricky at
first but there are some charts out
there that you can use as a preference
for 8 digit X values for alpha and one
of the best places to use these are
going to be in places where you've
already defined hex values and you just
want to add a city to it right or if you
just heart using hex values in general
you're those extra two digits might save
you the time it might take to look up
the RGB equivalent of a color now
browser support for a digit hex is
currently limited it's limited to
Firefox and Safari but you can also use
it in Chrome if you've enabled the
experimental web platform features
now not all hex RGB HSL values are easy
to remember right so if you if you're
writing plain CSS changing or adjusting
a color value often means having a
reference your graphics editor or color
tool and pre-process letters already
offer color functions right that can
apply transparency to colors have
functions that can darken them lighten
and blend them well CSS is about to take
a huge leap forward and get a color
modification function of its own the new
color mod function is going to let you
manipulate colors by taking a regular
color value and applying color adjusters
to it and these color adjusters are
like smaller functions within color mod
that for example can adjust the color
few the Alpha lightness saturation blend
colors together and lots lots lots more
now this bag for this function is still
a working draft but doesn't really have
browser so good browser support yet but
you can use it you can start using it in
post ESS it has a color function that
works exactly the way the color mod
function is supposed to work and in fact
color models named color and it was
recently renamed color mod and you can
begin experimenting with it in code pen
if you've been able to post CSS and the
color function atom so let's take a look
at some of those works so for example we
have a lightness adjuster here and that
lightens a color value by the specified
amount so for example 20% here you can
also take away lightness by setting a
negative percentage value but the best
part is that you can pass two or more
adjusters to your color mod function so
alongside alpha and lightness the hue
adjuster you see here changes the view
of a color by rotating the color wheel
by the specified amount so for example 5
degrees here now if you throw CSS
variables into the mix you can start to
see how useful the color mod function
can be for creating color palettes in
your design from a small set of colors
or from a single base color so here we
have a set of color variables and
they're created from a base color
crimson and it's using adjusters like
hue and lightness and it's even getting
the complementary colors just to create
strong visual contrast so now you can
change that base color to any value like
cornflower blue hot pink
iein crimson and the rest of the colors
are just going to adjust to that base
value the route the result is a
completely different color combination
each time so having a way to quickly
explore and manipulate colors on the fly
right while working in the browser with
a simple intuitive function like color
mine's going to be a huge huge one for
CSS and there's a really neat tool out
there called color video and you can use
these to compose your colors and
experiment with all the color functions
and all the adjusters
cool let's keep moving so selectors
level four there's a lots and lots of
new selectors on the wave and level four
now many of them are not supported by
browsers yet because it's still sort of
a working draft now I'll spend a little
bit of time covering some of the
selectors that I've found useful just a
myelin work and something to have the
most browser support and one of those is
Nexus so matches is a functional pseudo
class and it's going to help you write
complex selectors or descendant
selectors a lot faster and what it
really does is just provide a little
syntactic sugar for creating groups of
descendants direct child even sibling
selectors so matches is it takes of
regular selectors as argument so for
example here the selector is going to
match any button class that's a
descendant of card modal in form and
it's the same as writing the the full
selector group you see there below it
you can also pass photo classes so this
is going to make it a lot easier to for
example style your links this is
targeting the hover focus and active
visit it all at once and inside matches
you can pass through two elements and
combinators but you can still create
selectors using matches in a Combinator
outside that argument list so for
instance this is going to match any
paragraph that's a adjacent sibling of
image paragraph and form and as you can
see it just saves a little time right by
helping you to avoid writing out all
those selector combinations manually now
if you do a search for browser support
on matches you'll find that it's
implemented under the name any as it was
originally known but it looks like it's
going to be standardized in level 4
under the name matches those are the new
optionality pseudo classes that target
form controls like text fields text
areas and select and it targets them
based on whether they are optional or
required so you can spell them
differently and there's the ones I
really enjoyed using and had fun in my
own work are the validity pseudo classes
and these let you give your users visual
feedback just based on the validity of
the data they type into a field so for
example if you have an email input field
that's required you can define invalid
and valid pseudo classes that style then
just based on what you
types into the field so here's the Texas
if you've entered a valid email format
for example and then at pseudo-classes
to the mix sorry pseudo elements to the
mixin and it can be really useful it
gives you there's even more visual
feedback like you can display an icon
when the data goes from invalid to valid
so here's going to display that smiley
emoji for example now you can take
things a few steps further and display
an icon for both in valid and invalid
emails now normally you'll maybe use
JavaScript right to to do something like
this but we'll see the size you get
these input validation checks for free
now it's not going to check if the email
itself is a valid email it's just
validating the inputs according to the
validity semantics defined by HTML as a
few sites out there that can help you
keep track on browser support for these
level 4 selectors if you don't want to
individually search for them on for
example can I use com you can use CSS
for selectors com to see if your browser
supports some of these and it'll let you
know now finally some of the features I
talked about they're not they're new to
browsers right so they're not all
supported yet everywhere but that
shouldn't mean that you can't use them
or at least begin experimenting with
them right you're still able to use a
lot of those today while providing these
elegant fallbacks for browsers that
don't support them using feature queries
so the app support rule is bringing
native feature detection to CSS so I can
analyze whether or not a browser
supports a CSS property it looks a lot
like a media query so for example here
at the bottom this is querying for grid
layout and it's specifying the the
property value pair used to define a
grid display grid so then inside the
rule we're inside the supports rule we
are including all the the grid styles
for the content and then flexbox
currently has better support than grids
right so the browsers that don't support
read layout are going to layout the
content using the Flex box properties
defined outside the feature foyer so
it's kind of like having moderniser
which is a feature detection tool built
with JavaScript but right in the browser
it's going to perform a lot faster and
you can query multiple features at once
so for example here up top
we
the and operator and that's checking for
grid and writing modes of work and
writing mode is also a new CSS property
that changes the layout in alignment of
text so in browser supporting both
features users will do something like
this and browsers that don't support
these will simply display a normal
heading in paragraph which isn't a big
deal and as you can see there they have
really good browser support the feature
queries do and the supports rule and
browsers that don't support these
feature queries they're going to ignore
what's written inside the support rule
and just fall back to your regular CSS
and finally here's the list of the
browser support links I talked about
earlier that covers all the features I
talked today I talked about today and
yeah as with almost anything in
front-end web development and web
development there's so many features and
factors to consider when building your
projects so many of the things I've
covered are really enhancement features
right so you don't want to overdo it and
you want to be sure that your design and
content still still speaks to your users
even with some of these features in
place so hopefully what I talked about
today gives you lots of interesting new
ideas for your next project and as I
always tell students that treehouse
right this use all the guidelines and
suggestions and the things you learn and
see just the final works best for you
and your project in your team you don't
have to immediately use all the new
things and learn everything just because
they're popular at the moment right
matter of preference a lot of it so
what's important you develop your own
approach style and just because since
consistent about it right and that's all
I have to say thanks
I love tree huh